after Ben Higgins popped the question to
Lauren Bushnell on The Bachelor last
month the couple told eg that she joined
him in Colorado right now I'm going back
to work and focusing on our relationship
and moving to Denver now they're all
settled in and have already overcome a
few bumps honey we're gonna get you out
of here okay Lauren was there for Ben
when he got stuck in an elevator on
their first Denver date stuck in an
elevator
floor - no it was like for one on Friday
it was clear that Lauren fit right in
with Ben's pals check out this group
shot but they don't spend all their time
together earlier that day she headed to
brunch while he went for a run and look
here
Bushnell braved the snow alone on
Thursday shopping for household items
but every couple has their moments the
pair was caught in a tense conversation
on Saturday in this video both are
visibly upset in their car during a
shopping trip though they were also
spotted arm-in-arm and enjoyed a cooking
class together
that same night show everyone your apron
and on Monday
Lauren posted this adorable kissing shot
to Instagram a source tells et life is
good for the pair quote they are both so
in love with each other and will
definitely be one of the few couples to
make it from the show